[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
peace TV the solution for
[Music]
Humanity is there a father in this world
who would not try to provide for his
children and his
wife is there a father in this world who
would want to be locked up in a Cell way
from his family is there a father in
this world who would not
defend Justice and rights till the very
end ladies and gentlemen assalam alaikum
and welcome to a meeting entitled shared
values this is organized by Brent
Islamic Circle in association with forum
for social studies from Saudi Arabia
this is the first time that we've
actually done an interactive meeting
with Christian
speakers for those of you who think that
this is going to be a debate and a
slanging match you could actually leave
now because that's not the intention of
the evening the evening's intention is
to try and understand each each other's
um viewpoints a lot further and to see
what we have in
common basically the outline of the
evening will be that shortly there will
be a chronic
recitation and a recitation from the
Bible then we have Dr Reverend William
Taylor talking on Community Values and
the role of religion in The Next Century
then we have Dr n from India speaking
about family
values then a further 5 minutes for Dr
William Taylor to comment on any of the
earlier speakers
between 10: and 11: there'll be an hour
reserved for question and answers and
there will be purely written questions
there is paper on every seat if anybody
wants to ask a question please just
handw write it and put it on one of the
tables on the side and we'll try and
answer as many as
possible I'd like now to uh ask brother
T Sharif who is an A- level student
hoping to go to university this year to
do a chronic recitation they
[Music]
sh
for
[Music]
for for
well
[Music]
what
him in
[Music]
well
these are verses
36 to 42 of Surah number 42 Surah
Shah in the name of Allah
the most merciful The Giver of
Mercy whatever you are given here is but
the enjoyment of this
life but that which is with Allah is
better and more
lasting it is for those who believe and
put their trust in their
lord those who avoid the greater sins
and indecencies and when they are angry
even then forgive
those who respond to their lord and
establish regular prayer who conduct
their Affairs by Mutual
consultation who spend out of what we
bestow on them for
sustenance and those who when an
oppressive wrong is inflicted on them
are not cowed but help and defend
themselves the recompense for an injury
is an injury equal thereto in
degree but if a person forgives and
makes
reconciliation his reward is due from
Allah for Allah loveth not those who do
wrong but indeed if any do help and
defend himself even after a wrong done
to him against such there is no cause of
blame the blame is only against those
who oppress men with wrongdoing and
incidently transgress Beyond bounds
through the land defying right and
justice for such there will be a
chastisement
Grievous but indeed if any show patience
and
forgive that would truly be an affair of
great
resolution thank you very much da I'd
now like to ask uh brother Brian Gates
who is a local counselor in the bur of
herrow to do a short reading from the
Bible I'm reading two passages this
evening one from the Old Testament and
uh one from the new and the Old
Testament reading is in the Book of
Psalms and it's Psalm
133 behold how good and pleasant it is
when Brothers dwell in
unity it is like the precious oil upon
the head running down upon the beard
upon the beard of Aaron running down on
the collar of his
robes it is like the Jew of Heron which
falls on the mountains of Zion for there
the Lord has commanded the blessing life
forever
more and the second reading from the
Bible this evening is taken from the
gospel of Matthew in the New Testament
and it's chapter 25
verses 34-
46 then the king will say to those at
his right hand come oh blessed of my
father inherit the Kingdom prepared for
you from the foundation of the world for
I was hungry and you gave me food I was
thirsty and you gave me drink I was a
stranger and you welcomed me I was naked
and you clothed me I was sick and you
visited me I was in prison and you came
to me then the righteous will answer him
Lord when did we see thee hungry and
feed thee or thirsty and give thee drink
and when did we see thee a stranger and
welcome thee or naked and clothe thee
and when did we see thee sick or in
prison and visit thee and the King will
answer them truly I say to you as you
did it to one of the least of these my
brethren you did it to
me then he will say to those on his left
hand depart from me you cursed into the
Eternal fire prepared for the devil and
his angels for I was hungry and you gave
me no food I was thirsty and you gave me
no drink I was a stranger and you did
not welcome me naked and you did not
clothe me sick and in prison and you did
not visit me then they will also answer
Lord when did we see the hungry or
thirsty or a stranger or naked or sick
or in prison and did not minister to
thee then he will answer them truly I
say to you as you did it not to one of
the least of these you did it not to me
and they will go away into internal
punishment but the righteous into
eternal
life thank you very much
indeed now I'd like to welcome Reverend
Dr William
Taylor who is an Anglican priest and
area dean of eling in West London his
academic background is in Middle Eastern
languages politics and theology he
worked on his PhD thesis on non-muslim
minorities in the Ottoman Empire while
training for the priesthood at Cambridge
formerly on the Archbishop of
canterbury's personal staff at Lambeth
Palace his responsibilities were for
relations with Orthodox Churches
especially in the near East he was a
chaplain to to the British Embassy in
Aman Jordan while acting as a consultant
for orthodox relations to the dasis of
Jerusalem he has traveled extensively in
most of the Turkish speaking republics
in turkey and every Arab country except
morania he is a writer and broadcaster
and as he's given me such a long
introduction maybe I could ask him to
cut his speech down by a couple of
minutes I'm very grateful for this
opportunity to be with you this evening
and to listen to views and to share my
own based on my own experience of
working with Islam in the Middle East
and in this country my subject is one
which I believe is especially important
at the moment to all societies and
particularly to those who are in a
position to affect change within Society
that's to say those in political
Authority the religious leadership
academic institutions and those in
public service business diplomats as
well as decent men and women of all
walks of life the question is
this what should be the role of
religious faith in defining a
community's values Direction and even
public
policy we can be sure of one thing this
question is not going to go away even in
the liberal secular
West last year the center for strategic
and international studies in Washington
published a book entitled religion the
missing dimension of
statecraft the whole thesis of This Book
Is that public policy makers especially
in the west have consistently
underestimated the potency of religious
faith ining public
policy in Western
policym who could have predicted for
example the explosion of so-called
ethnic and religious fervor which marked
the collapse of the former
Yugoslavia in any case such foresight
would I believe have demanded more
historical education than our political
classes have been known for similarly
the religious leadership must play a
more Dynamic and creative role in
conflict
resolution now in much of the world we
have underestimated for too long the
ability of religion of cultures and
religions to create divisions we have
failed to grasp what that can mean
particularly for young people even more
than ethnicity religion discriminates
sharply between people for example a
person can be half French and half Arab
and simultaneously a citizen of two
countries it is more difficult to be
half Catholic and half
Muslim one of the best known Christian
theologians the German Roman Catholic
Theologian Hans Kung gave a lecture in
London last year entitled towards a
global ethic his thesis and mine today
is that the search for peace between the
world faiths is one of the most urgent
tasks facing humankind he said this Hans
Kung without peace between the religions
war between the
civilizations no peace among the
religions without dialogue between the
religions no dialogue between the
religions without investigation of the
foundations of the
religions I believe that analysis to be
correct and I want to give four pointers
this evening and I will be brief which
might be helpful to people of faith if
in particular to Muslims and Christians
I do not believe that this is a
specialist activity for academics and
religious leaders but needs to inform
all aspects of Private Practice and
public policy especially in religiously
plural societies such as our own the
four principles I want to suggest are
these and these are the four principles
which the Archbishop of Canterbury used
when he met the religious leadership in
al-azhar in Egypt and this is speaking
especially in Christian relations with
Islam firstly friendship not
hostility
secondly understanding not
ignorance thirdly reciprocity not
exclusivism and fourthly cooperation not
confrontation and I'll briefly elaborate
these headings so firstly friendship not
hostility
I choose to use the word friendship
rather than the word tolerance tolerance
I believe is often linguistically
misused to mean an indifference towards
those things we don't particularly care
about for example I tolerate your
smoking but it really gets up my nose
true friendship is the uh context where
differences can be held
harmoniously and where mutually
exclusive belief Bel can be held without
antagonism or hatred Dr Albert hurani a
worldclass scholar of the Arab and
Muslim World wrote this nobody can write
with meaning about the world of Islam if
he does not bring into it some sense of
a living relationship with those of whom
he
writes now hanan's description of a
living relationship is vital in any
dialogue either between individuals or
between institutional religions on a
more formal level this is not just an
exchange of ideas but is also much more
simple in these terms an exchange of
hospitality and hum kindness in any case
the practice of hospitality is Central
to all the major world faiths it
certainly is to Islam and has shaped
many cultures not least the Kaleidoscope
of cultures which is modern multifaith
Britain that's the first principle
second one understanding not
ignorance I continue to find it
extraordinary how ignorant people of
Faith are of each other be they Muslim
Hindu sik Jew Jane or Christian yet
ignorance is the most terrible of
cultural diseases for from it stem fear
understanding and intolerance to take
one example Islam has been consistently
misunderstood and misrepresented in the
west and it continues to be Dr Aziz al-
armi professor of Islamic Studies in the
University of exitor has shown how the
Western caricature of Islam has
typically gone through three
phases prior to the 16th century
Reformation it was caricatured as
intolerant and evil during the 18th
century Enlightenment as strange and
ridiculous and in modern times as a
faith to be
feared professor John Esposito from
Georgetown University Washington
elaborated this in a paper given in
Amman Jordan and I'm going to quote from
it he said this we live in a world in
which it remains common to speak of or
see headlines with the terms militant
Islam resurgent Islam fundamentalist
Islam Islamic bombs Islamic extremism
Islamic Fanatics Islamic guillas and
Islamic
terrorism even the former Secretary
General of NATO caused a stir when he
spoke of Islam as the new communism a
remark which brought criticism and a
hasty
retraction this is a cartoon comic word
world view and in it Islam is perceived
as a threat to Western civilization but
it is not news to point out the more
accurate picture the historic debt of
Western scholarship to Islamic thought
and and practice nor of the Contemporary
manifestations of outstanding
cooperation Jordan and Syria both now
have formal institutes for the
advancement of dialogue between Islam
and
Christianity the Jordanian one is a
particularly exciting example of an
Institute funded and promoted by Royal
patronage and which is set now to expand
its base for dialogue to include Judaism
a tripartite dialogue of the three
abrahamic faiths Islam Judaism and
Christianity or it isn't news to speak
of the many excellent centers for
religious dialogue in South Asian
culture in India many of which I have
visited and which are too numerous to
list nor to speak of the years of
patient and often difficult work for
example in Britain which went into the
shaping of a new agreed syllabus for
Religious Education in British
schools this excellent syllabus draws on
all the major faiths in producing a
syllabus to educate British children
which should do away with much of the
past
ignorance this is a relatively new
situation for people in Britain only
within the past 30 to 40 years has
Britain become a multicultural and
multi-religious
Society take just one small concrete
example in myself in my school education
teaching about any other Faith than
Christianity simply did not exist
my six-year-old godson however spent an
evening recently explaining the
difference between duar and guy
forknight this can only be positive in
creating a culture of understanding and
not
ignorance then thirdly reciprocity and
exclusivism if we seriously want peace
and Harmony on our over crowded Planet
then friendship and
respect we must have towards people of
other faiths in a mutual way this of
course is more difficult for some
religions than for others I'm going to
take two specific examples now Islam and
Christianity Islam and Christianity are
both missionary faiths they make
absolute claims and are anxious to
promote their faiths Muslims are
commanded in the Holy Quran to act as
Witnesses for man kind just as
Christians are commanded in Holy
scripture to go into the world and
preach the
gospel so the question to be put to both
Muslims and Christians is
this can believers who really believe
passionately in their hearts that theirs
is a missionary Faith really be
committed to
dialogue my own answer to this is that
they must be and that they have a
distinguished history of doing so so in
the past as in the present take yourself
as an individual as an example whatever
your religious position now ask yourself
this question would you say of
yourself that because you have a clearly
and lovingly held identity within a
particular religious faith that your
willingness to listen to learn and to
grow is diminished by that in any case
no religious Faith encourages its
members to commend their faith
arrogantly irresponsibly or
deceitfully now move on from this and
this is a question addressed to any who
are in a majority
religion is a majority Faith willing to
offer the same rights and privileges
that it expects for its own members
this is a particularly urgent issue
whether it addresses minority Muslim
groups in the west or whether it
addresses minority Christian groups in
the Muslim
World in Britain there is a particular
urgency as we address the question of
Muslim schools as independent
institutions financed partly by the
state in my own area of London eing
moves to create a Muslim School were
eventually blocked by the local
Authority on the grounds that it would
create interreligious conflict the
majority community in that part of
London being seik and which Community
had led a vocal campaign against
it my own view on this is to emphasize
the positive contribution which South
Asian culture has made and is making to
British life I believe that the solid
commitment to religious Faith from this
community has helped to raise the
profile of all religious faiths in
Britain British culture had come to
think of religion as unimportant a
society which have begun to assume that
everything has its price and can be
measured and assessed in quantitative
terms has had to see some things
religious Faith as Price
Less and this is certain the view of the
leadership of of the mainstream churches
in Britain the Archbishop of Canterbury
in a recent address to the Muslim IMA at
Alazar University in Cairo spoke of his
role in guaranteeing religious freedom
for all
citizens in prisons and hospitals
Christian chaplain help to ensure that
the religious needs of those of other
faiths are met the Church of England has
helped to finance a major academic and
policymaking study on the role of the
faith communities within Britain I would
want to ask perhaps a bit provocatively
in how many other countries would the uh
established religion be prominent in
securing the religious rights of those
who are not of their
faith so to move on and to conclude
finally cooperation not confrontation
in spite of all the complexities there
are many areas in the way we organize
ourselves as societies where the
religious Traditions can and do develop
wide areas of
cooperation the religious faiths
Christianity and Islam can and do
provide a strong basis for joint
commitment to Humanity's struggle to
overcome evil disease and poverty let me
point to just a few of these areas of
cooperation and the context I want to
set this in is
society devout followers of all faiths
are encouraged to be responsible
citizens and good
neighbors this in turn not only involves
a certain lifestyle in community but a
private lifestyle which takes seriously
a commitment to respect and to love
others in the Contemporary Indian
context of course
this was superbly and incomparably
demonstrated by map mandhi the
commitment to moral values the
importance of the family respect for a
nonviolent way of settling disputes care
for the poor and the underprivileged and
a sense of obligation and accountability
to the one who judges all human
life common religious Faith would say
that Justice and integrity should be at
the heart of society laws of society
require a moral
Foundation experience shows that human
beings cannot be improved by the
imposition of law
alone this understanding affects our
concepts of Justice it affects those who
administer the law it weighs in the
balance those who rule Justice must mean
justice for all so to
conclude we look for coop ation in
working for peace based on tolerance and
understanding and this of course ties
closely with work for peace in general
but is also much broader wherever we
look in the world xenophobia is an enemy
to racial and religious
Harmony religion when it is hijacked by
extremists will always do
this work for tolerance is not
accidental but it needs to be sustained
and vigorous violence is always violence
whatever the justification murder is
always murder especially when it is done
in the name of God so to sum up my
argument is that religious faith is
vital to the well-being and Harmony of
society and it will continue to be so
and the Muslim Community in Britain has
a vital role in this in challenging our
secular
society there is is no society which has
survived without it that's religious
Faith the collapse of all formerly
atheist States has proved this Beyond
doubt religious faith is not about to go
away now nor in the future so policy
makers need to be aware of
this religious faith if properly
interpreted is an enormous positive
Force for good in just some of the areas
I've outlined and I remain utterly
convinced that the role of religions
Christianity and Islam in particular
within our own Society is a vital
ingredients in the search for peace
order and Harmony in our own Society
thank you very
much thank you very much Dr Taylor for
sticking well to time and keeping the
meeting running on time thank you I'd
like to introduce Dr Zakir Nik he is
president of the Islamic Research
Foundation is a medical doctor by
profession but has dedicated a lot of
his life to spreading the the truth of
Islam worldwide especially amongst
millions of english- speaking
audiences uh he has more than 100
lectures and debates and symposia
available on audio and video cassettes
uh which are extremely popular I've
actually got a whole page which I won't
read out and I think when you hear him
uh his qualities will be obvious to I'd
like to ask him to come and speak on
family values and to try and stick to
the topic of family values for the next
2025 minutes
inshah alhamdulillah
respected Reverend Dr Jamal badwi my
respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings may peace blessings and mercy
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala beyond all of
you the topic allotted to me for this
Christian Muslim dialogue is family
values in
Islam family values in Islam should not
be judged by what individual Muslims do
or what the Muslim Society does it
should be judged according to the
authentic sources that's the Glorious
Quran and
the I have divided the family
values into three broad headings as
those related to the children that sons
and the daughters as those related to
the spouses that is the husband and wife
and those related to the
parents that is father and
mother let's first discuss the family
values related to the
children that's the daughter and the son
the Glorious Quran says in Surah Anam
chapter number 6 verse number 151 as
well as Surah isra chapter number 17
verse number 31 that kill not your
children for want of sustainance
for it is Allah who will give sust to
you and your children for killing of
children is a major
crime killing of infants by the male or
female is prohibited in the Glorious
Quran and a special reference is made in
Sur 81 verse number n that when the
female child is buried alive and she'll
be questioned for what crime was he
killed a special reference is made that
do not kill the female children
especially because in the olden days and
especially in Arabia before the Quran
was revealed it was a very common
practice that when a daughter was born
very often she was buried
alive
alhamdulillah after the revelation of
the Glorious Quran this evil practice
has discontinued in the Arab countries
but yet unfortunately it does persist in
countries where I come from like India
and certain
countries many to
culture and according to a
survey done by em beckin on the BBC on
the program letter die the topic was
assignment she said that every day in
India more than 3,000 fetuses are being
aborted after they identified that the
females Quran not only prohibits the
killing of children especially females
it even the thought of a person becoming
sad at the news of the birth of female
child the Glorious Quran says in certain
hell chapter number 16 verse number 58
the Glorious Quran says that when news
is B to one of them of the birth of a
female child his face darkens and he's
filled with inward
grief and he hides his face in shame
from the people and thinks that should
he let her live live in contempt or
should he bury her alive ah what an evil
Choice Quran rebukes the thought of a
person becoming sad at the news of a
female child and our beloved Prophet
said in say Muslim Vol number four
Hadith number 63 64 that the prophet
said that anyone who upbring two
daughters correctly with kindness and
love till they mature they will be as
close to this these two fingers on the
day of judgment
and another Hadith says that anyone who
up brings two daughters with love and
compassion till they become mature they
shall enter
Heaven once there was a
person who kissed his son and placed him
on his lap in front of the Prophet
Prophet Obed and said that he should
have even kissed his daughter and placed
her on the other lap the first guidance
given the Glorious Quran to the whole of
humankind is
in 96 verse number 1 to5 he
says read recite or Proclaim in the name
of thy Lord who created who created the
human beings from something which clings
a leash like substance read thy Lord is
most Bountiful who taught men the use of
the pen who taught me men that we did
not
know the first guidance given to the
humankind in the Glorious Quran is to
read and the prophet said that it is
obligatory for every Muslim man or woman
to acquire knowledge and the prophet
told the parents that it is obligatory
that they should educate the children
especially the
daughters let's discuss Family Values
related with the spouses that the and
wife the Glorious Quran refers to the
woman as aasa that's a fortress against
the devil unlike other religions many of
which who consider the woman as an
instrument of the
devil and a good woman she keeps the
husband on the straight path on theim
and prevents him from going on the wrong
track our beloved Prophet said mm Salli
wasallam in say bukari volume number 7
in The Book of nikah chapter number
three Hadith number four that oh young
people Whoever has the means to get
married should get married for it will
help you to lower your gaze and guard
your modesty in Islam we encouraged
early marriage if you have the means you
should get married earlier and the
Glorious Quran says that if you don't
have the means keep yourself modest till
Allah subhana wa ta'ala gives you the
means and the prophet said it's a Hadi
narrated by anas pleas with him that
anyone who marries completes half his
de half is religion so one question
answer time somebody asked me that does
it mean that if I marry twice I complete
my full Dean my full
religion what did the prophet mean that
marriage completes half your
Dean what the prophet meant was marriage
prevents you from promiscuity from
fornication from sexuality which are
half the evil in the society only if you
marry do you have an opportunity to be a
husband or wife only if you marry do you
have an opportunity to be a father or a
mother which are very important duties
in Islam so irrespective whether you
marry once or twice yet you only
complete half your de the Glorious Quran
says in Surah Room chapter number 30: 21
that amongst his signs Allah subhana wa
ta'ala has created for you
mates of like nature
so that you may dwell in Tranquility
with them and he has put love and mercy
between your
hearts the Glorious Quran in Surah 4:
211 refers to marriage as a m a sacred
Covenant and for a marriage to solemnize
the permission of both would be husband
and wife is equally important that's the
boy and the
girl the Quran said in Surah 4: number
19 that do not inherit the woman
against the wishes according to beloved
Prophet there Inari Vol number seven in
the book of n chapter number 43 Hadith
number 138 that once a lady by the name
of she approached the prophet and said
that she has been forced by her father
to marry a man who she did not like and
the prophet nullified the
marriage permission of both boy and girl
is equally important for a marriage to
solize in Islam
and in Islam we prefer calling the woman
folk by the correct terminology not by
the English word housewife you know
because she's not married to the house
to be referred to as housewife you know
housewife means wife of the house we
prefer calling the women folk as hom
makers because they make the home they
build the home and she's married to an
equal in Islam men and women are
equal equality does not mean ality and
the Glorious Quran says in Surah Bak CH
2 verse number
228 that the women have rights as
against them on terms Equitable but the
men have a degree of Advantage many of
the men including many Muslims they
misunderstand the meaning of this words
and they think that men are superior
some of them think the Quran says men
are superior and they quote a ver of the
Glorious Quran in Surah 4:34 it says
that the men are the of the wom comes
from the root which means to stand up
for what it actually means that the men
have one degree of extra responsibility
in supporting the women they don't have
one degree extra superiority in bossing
over the woman they have one degree
additional responsibility in supporting
the woman because the verse continues
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has given
one more strength than the other and the
Glorious Quran says in
chapter number four verse number 19 that
treat your wives on footing of equity
and kindness and aside my talk by
quoting a verse from the Glorious Quran
from Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number 187 which
says that they are your garments and you
are their garments the roles of husband
and wife in a family are that like
garments know garments are used to
conceal husband wife should conceal each
other's faults they used for protecting
they should protect each other they're
used for beautification husband and wife
should beautify one another it's a role
of a hand and
glove and in Islam the men are supposed
to be the bread earner in Islam in the
Family Life in Islam a woman she need
not earn her living before she's married
it's the duty of the father and the
brother and after she's married it's the
duty of the husband and the son to look
after her boarding clothing lodging and
all Financial aspects she need not work
for a living she is financially more
secured as compared to the man in
Islam but if she wishes to work if there
are financial problems she may work as
long as the atmosphere is Islamic and
Islamic work and within the PV of the
Islamic
Sharia even during marriage she is on
the receiving
end the Quran in 4 vers number four that
give to the woman a marital gift end da
that means for a marriage to sermonize
aah has to be
given the husband give to the wouldbe
wife a maral gift it's
compul but in the country where I come
from that's India the society is the
opposite the do is given by the woman to
the husband would be husband and it's a
cultural practice which has poisoned the
whole society you know if a woman has to
marry a
graduate she has to give 100,000 rupees
if it's an engineer she has to give
500,000 Rupees if it's a doctor 1
million rupees as they are selling you
know hers and cattles in the
marketplace in
Islam it's prohibited to demand any dowy
from the wife willingly If the parents
of the wife give certain gifts they most
welcome but demanding directly or
indirectly is prohibited you cannot say
that my son he likes to travel in a
Mercedes car indicating that you require
a Mercedes car in
do my son wres to live in a four-bedroom
flat indicating that in marriage I will
marry my son to your daughter Only If
You Give a four-bedroom
apartment demanding directly or
indirectly Dy from the wouldbe wife is
not allowed in
Islam
and if suppose the woman becomes a widow
unfortunately she even gets her share
and a woman even inherits she even get
maintainance in the period of financial
support and even if divorce takes place
she gets financial support and there is
a great misconception amongst the people
Regarding why does Islam allow a man to
have more than one
wife time doesn't permit us to go into
the details of why it allows but just in
brief I like to say that in fact all the
religions if you read the scriptures
they did give
permission for the men to marry as many
wives as they
wanted no religious scripture that I
know of tells a man to marry one except
the Glorious
Quran in fact if you read the Hindu
scriptures they give permission to as
many as you want it's later on that the
Hindu priests or the Indian law
restricted the marriage for a Hindu man
to only one wife even the Old Testament
even the Bible if you read if you read
the first Kings chter number 11 verse
number three Solomon had 700 wives
Abraham had three wives it's later on
that the rabbi and the church put a
restriction Islam says in N 4 verse
number three that marry women of a
choice in two threes or fours but if you
can't do justice marry only one and the
reason the people want they can ask me a
question answer
time but it is for the modesty of the
woman that a man is allowed to marry
more than one wife it's not a f it's not
compulsory that a man should marry some
people think it's far neither is it that
you'll get more blessings if you marry
more than one wife it's optional it's
optional but if you marry the criteria
is you should do justice if you don't do
justice you are in trouble that divorce
should never be given under normal
circumstances it is at a last resort if
the husband wife cannot get along as a
last result under normal circumstances
should avoid it to the best ability you
can at the last
resort and in some societies you can
give divorce in some societies you can't
some religions give permission while the
others don't some have certain
restrictions the Bible says in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 5 verse
number 3132 that it has been said of the
old times that whosoever put a woman
away putteth a wife away you should give
a bill of divorce that was the law of
Moses peace be upon him that if you want
to give a divorce give a bill of divorce
but Jesus peace be upon him said but I
say unto you that whosoever putteth away
his wife except for fornication he ask
her to commit adultery that means only
in case of fornication can you give
divorce according to the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 5 verse number 31
and 32 and there's a lot of
misconception regarding
divorce in Islam basically you can
classify under five headings that one is
mutually given both husband and wife
second is unilaterally by the husband by
the will of the husband he wishes